- The headlines say
that former-president Trump was exonerated
in violently clearing out
protestors for a photo op
at Lafayette Square last year.
Those headlines are wrong.
First of all, this report
was incredibly narrow.
It looked only to the actions
of the U.S. Park Police.
It didn't look to the Secret Service.
It didn't interview Attorney
General William Barr.
It didn't talk about all of
the Bureau of Prisons Officers
who were in Lafayette Square that day.
And second of all, the facts
that are in this report are
actually incredibly damning if
you actually read the report.
It does appear that the
U.S. Park Police had a plan
to clear protesters in
order to put up a fence.
However, the U.S. Park Police had no idea
the president was going to be on site
until Bill Barr came out, informed them,
to which the Park Police was incredulous.
Then minutes later,
before the Park Police could
even implement their plan
to give warnings to the protestors,
the U.S. Secret Service jumped the gun
and started violently attacking
the protestors on site,
and on top of that, the U.S.
Park Police were not authorized
to use CS gas and pepper balls,
which the Secret Service
and the Bureau of Prisons
employees were actually using.
There is much more to the story,
and this is not an exoneration.
This still appears to be
exactly what it looks like.